I wonder if you have thoughts about grouting sheets or grouting pads to reduce inflammation?
If so, is there a brand or product that you'd recommend?
Grouting sheets and grouting pads, yes, can be used.
We currently are out of grouting pads, and I don't know that we'll get them back in.
We might have a few left if you call Megan next week.
We'll see grouting sheets we have a lot left, and we're actually having a...
Pretty sure Dustin's having a huge sale this weekend, Black Friday.
So, do look at your e-mail, see if you're going to e-mail on Thursday or Friday,
with a discount off the grouting sheets.
Now, you could use a grouting sheet for a pad, too.
I mean, you could keep it folded up and sit on it and your chair and then plug it into the grouting.
So, the grouting sheets are more versatile that way.
Maybe they're not as stylish as the full type grouting pad,
that the grouting sheets are larger, and they can be used for more things.
And then tie that into the question from the chat,
would it be okay to use a grouting pad with the rife machine?
If you're going to use a grouting pad or a grouting sheet with the rife machine,
I suggest you use it on just the lower half of your body.
So, those that are using the rife machine at night,
I always recommend that you only use the grouting sheet.
You put the grouting sheet at the lower half of your bed,
because you don't want the frequencies to get drawn through the ground.
So, when you have something connected to a grouting,
it's going to attract frequencies,
so we don't want to lose them and not have them go through your body.
Now, again, it depends on how you use it.
So, you're late, you sleep only on your back,
and you have a grouting sheet under the fitted sheet,
so you're laying on top of a grouting sheet,
and you put the bulb on your belly,
and it stays on your belly all night long.
So, theoretically, the frequencies are going through you with it to the ground,
so you're still getting all those frequencies.
But that's not real.
I mean, most people are rolling around.
The bulbs lay next to them part of the night.
It's not always on their belly.
So, therefore, I tell people to put the grouting sheets
on the lower half of the bed.
That's better operation.